je crois
il
à
[Musique]
c'est le décor
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un homme en faire un jour un slip
superman je suppose que ça doit être un
moment qui vont dire que ça n'allait pas
et du coup je le porte à chaque saint
valentin n'ont voulu porter la
ben oui à chaque c'est un avantage en
rapporte sans rigoler mais oui depuis
c'est vrai on peut le voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dire que je tâte applaudi pas je te prie
quand je parle de dire que j'ai deux
passions dans la vie tu vois c'est
installer des fenêtres et casser les
animateurs et quand je te vois je vais
dicter
c'est un peu comme les prime de de
l'ormeau toi tu existes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais avant de démarrer prononcé
quelques mots déjà et je m'adresse aux
plus jeunes d'entre nous ne fait des
paris que quand vous êtes sûr de les
gagner